I'm I'm I'm lactose intolerant so I've
had to reject a lot of Milkshakes
unfortunately I always feel bad hey I'm
Paul Dano and uh I'm being forced to
talk about myself
[Music]
the Batman
why is she still tired
there was some resistance in me at first
because
I was didn't want his glasses to be like
stylish or something but there was
something about the clear frames with
the mask and with this the Saran Wrap
which is something we added where it
just felt right it felt really right and
I cannot quantify why I love Batman I
think Gotham is the coolest and our back
lot was just insane and the L train over
us and that Diner and that was a night
filming that Diner scene where you
somehow some out of body or you step out
and you go like a movie like there's a
movie Moment by Matt having such a
specific point of view and a new one it
gave me a lot of freedom you know like
this is this Riddler like I'm not gonna
worry about the other ones or the comics
or like you know I tried to take all the
archetypal energy I could from the
comics and I read a ton of them and I'm
writing a comic now about the Riddler
and I was shocked by how much I loved
putting out the film and engaging with
that fan base being again a fan myself
and how much fervor there is around the
Batman you think you'll be remembered
you're pathetic
you're gonna die oh no no no no no no
nobody
no
no
I also think that like that's why like
why would we keep making these right
like it's to reinterpret and it's to
reinterpret it for the times as well
um to keep
investigating a character in a world so
I think to for people like Matt and Tim
Burton and Crystal and like for and then
whoever's gonna carry it next like I
think it's got to be an artist with a
point of view who's taking that
character in that City for the the the
the the time that we're in Little Miss
Sunshine
so who do you hang out with
no
I auditioned when I was 18 and for the
next couple years anytime I came to La I
would meet with the directors Jonathan
Dayton and Valerie Ferris and they would
basically be checking to see if I looked
too old that character of Dwayne
I knew him and I there was a specific
friend I thought about when playing that
part and I didn't know how many other
people I guess would also know him
because it felt like they did once the
the movie came out one of the first
things we filmed is uh there's a dinner
table scene quite early on in the film I
think they used two cameras around us
and there's a lot of family talking and
a lot of uh action verbally and I'm
trying to participate in that but but
without speaking I mean I think I tried
to experience the world like that a
little bit right to communicate without
speaking and use the notepad we did some
really fun in-character rehearsals for
that as well where we got in the van and
went bowling and went out to uh the
diner and I didn't talk and I have some
really good memories from that film
being stuck in the back of a hot van
with Alan Arkin who was such a joy and
everybody always you know asks if Steve
Carell was the funniest person on set
and Steve was just the love ugliest and
he's very funny but Alan Arkin it was
just a razor sharp wit
a lot of women did I have no reason to
lie to you not one woman a lot of
you heard what I said
did it go in anywhere I was listening to
Sufjan Stevens new album which had just
come out that's uh summer I think and I
just played it for John Valley said I'm
gonna go see him in concert so me and
John Valentini Collette and maybe some
others went to see him uh and then we
went and hung out at I think the Chateau
merman afterwards like drinking tequila
and then they ended up putting a Sufjan
song in the film
[Music]
foreign
I do think that there's a really
interesting thing for actors that you
have to learn to trust like your
thoughts and I don't think I knew that
at the time but I looked back on that
now and I go oh I wish I'd known I could
just really trust
what I was thinking and and feeling and
that if you're open that it'll it'll be
received
There Will Be Blood
you just brought the swelling
yes so just give me five hundred dollars
in cash right now and I'll tell you
where it is
I'll tell you what I'll do son I'll give
you a hundred dollars now and if it
proves to be a promising lease and give
you a thousand dollars six hundred
dollars
I was cast at the last minute I remember
spending the day or two I had of prep
sitting in the Sunday church in my
church with my script and I think with
some music and I started learning the
scenes and the lines we filmed on I
believe like a 40
000 acre ranch uh in Marfa Texas
it was the summer and I think we did
some six day weeks and it was period
wool clothes and I so wish I remembered
more but I remember I remember sweating
I remember the sun I remember seeing
Daniel for the first time who I had
known and we'd done a film together
called The Battle of Jack and Rose and
I love him but I remember showing up
there and seeing him
in his clothes and hearing his voice and
you know uh going ocean I think we would
shake hands at the end of the day
sometimes I think it's a much more
intuitive natural thing than maybe it
sounds because it sort of makes sense if
you don't get along with the character
to stand across the room from each other
because
I think you're building up the energy
that's going towards the scene
yes
for the Lord can't hear you Daniel this
show him go ahead and speak to him it's
all right
yes down on your knees
to the sky and
it was so clear the film that was being
made and what Daniel and Paul were
bringing to it I tried to do was asked
for in the writing that I think occurs
um in this character I feel like the
word possession feels important like how
to just
let um the possession of the scene and
the words and the spirit passed through
you I'll never forget laying there in
the blood and hearing Daniel say the
last line of the film but the way he
says it
I'm finished
I don't think anybody else would
have done what he did
Swiss army man
I had actually seen their music videos
uh one late one night in a hotel room
while I was filming a movie called Youth
and we were on night shoot so I was
staying up late so other videos I was
like brilliant I was like what is this
two days later maybe I got an email from
my agent being like these guys called
the Daniels have a script they want to
send you and I was like no Evan way and
I opened it and I read the first two
pages
which involved my character riding a
corpse
farting jet ski
I was like well this is it this is
exactly you know who I am in almost
every script there's a no I don't I
don't say a key but there's like a
moment an image
something where you're like that's my
first you know like hook in with that
one as I said it was the opening scene
so when we were out there and I was on
this wakeboard with a dummy you know and
singing at the top of my lungs and the
music is beautiful in that film and
awesome and so even that it just fills
you up the the the music
I will say I was very grateful that my
scene partner was Daniel Radcliffe and
you know I had to carry him quite a bit
that was pretty brutal I think I think I
think it was a pretty tiring shoot I
think I was so like sore every day even
though we were having fun tired sore
it felt like really good to be with
those guys Daniel Quan and Daniel Shiner
to be with them in the woods you know
making this crazy movie and if you
haven't seen it it is one of the I I
would say just go watch the first five
minutes and you can choose whether to
keep going
love and mercy
stay at home in the studio
it's what I need to do
can I promise when you come back I will
have stuff for you that will blow your
minds
John Cusack and I play Brian Wilson I
think John and I met on my last day in
his first day we didn't communicate
about playing the Brian's I think we
trusted in Brian uh in the character of
Brian and in the sort of essence and
spirit of Brian and I think that the way
that that film and script was structured
we were certainly not trying to get to a
place of impersonation or imitation I
think we were trying to just get inside
of a very complicated you know artist
nobody wants you don't want fake Brian
Wilson's voice but I mean I think you
can feel the heart soul connection as
for an audience watching an actor if
they're actually playing or singing
something and I guess Brian approved
because I was I was hoping to sing and
play the stuff for Brian's alone in the
film so there's a moment in the film
where I play some a God only knows and
some of you still believe in me and some
Surf's Up
but what living to me
and God only knows what I'd be we filmed
in the actual Studio that he recorded
Pet Sounds in back in 65 and they played
the stuff in the studio live and I got
to work with them on camera the physical
thing of learning to play some songs and
having to stretch my voice again I used
to sing but and that was uh incredible
experience for me I was given access to
a lot of session tapes and to hear Brian
working with the musicians and it's one
of the best experiences I've had as an
actor and I think that's in large part
to the music it was a great gift to me
that part and that experience similarly
to like swissy I think it relit some
part of me I don't know what part but
something got reactivated maybe
good chocolate's cut for a second please
for somebody who struggled he wanted to
give people something I think he wanted
to make them smile and he made me smile
okay
my name is Jay
Jen and Jay
and a Kato go ahead
we are animal lovers I can't remember
what I'd done right before okja but I
know that I needed it to play more of a
hero type of character or somebody who
stands for something and that felt
important and right in that moment for
wherever I was in my life I loved that
Pig I mean I remember bong jinho showing
me a drawing of a pig
years before this and I was like that's
it like that's the movie like this pig
like beautiful it depended on the scene
but there was a couple of uh people who
held a sort of a gray head
um that was there for us which was great
because even a sort of grayish looking
animal is better than nothing you can
project onto a breezy in fact like we
all like stuffed animals like you know
like it's pretty clear we are able to
give these things personalities and feel
from them and I remember doing there's a
moment right where I Jay pulls The Shard
of glass I think from Oak just foot and
I loved the you know the tenderness of
that moment
ocean
you fill up my senses
I love my my LF guys we're still in
touch I had a great time there in Seoul
um sitting on the Han River with those
guys drinking cheap Soju and
um I just had a really uh I had a really
good time
night and day
all right
oh my God just die I have a a really
clear memory of watching Cruz work with
the stunt team
and I remember seeing how he considered
the audience and the impact of the
stunts on the audience and how
passionate and rigorous he was about
that and that was a real lesson I had
not been around that before I had not
seen an actor consider the audience and
the impact of how
the stunt and the cut of the camera
would feel for the audience and I took
that with me I thought okay I would say
most of the work that I've like done
isn't about that relationship but I
think it's fascinating and interesting
to consider it in the right thing I
always think that the content lends
itself to the form and there's a group
of people there's a temperature and a
vibration on set there's the way the
director works there's the way that the
crew works I mean one of my favorite DPS
I worked with is Roger deakins because
this crew is so quiet there's like uh
and it brings a focus and I really
appreciate that and I know when I was
directing I wanted it to feel like when
my actors step on set everything changes
escape the dannemora
bro
it was probably the hardest shoot I've
ever done like seven months
prison just the color of those walls and
Ben sort of went to Great Lengths to
have things feel as authentic as
possible and we shot a lot of
relocations and then some prisons and a
lot of our extras were x-cons and I
really like how it turned out I have to
say I was really impressed with what Ben
did and I guess I don't always know and
I'm doing something
you forget I think that it is going to
be really entertaining and really
because like once you're in the the
prison and the reality of it it's like
oh there's murder and then it turns out
to be a pretty good piece of
entertainment
I do remember being in those pipes
actually that was a that was man one
time bernusso showed up they were trying
to like measure out like could we do it
in the actual size of the pipe that was
there he walked on set nope you know
what like right because like I mean we
could barely fit in them I liked uh that
Sledgehammer I liked Breaking Up Down
the Walls that was fun
fablements
Steven Spielberg making a film that's
based on his childhood it is uh
semi-autobiographical he wrote it with
Tony Kushner who's one of my favorite
writers and yeah it's I think still hard
for me to comprehend that Stephen
Spielberg would ask me to play his
father or a version of his father this
is of course a project that's very
personal to him and was to all of us and
and really meaningful it's about a kid
who discovers a family secret and then
how
how the Cameron movies play a part in
understanding
who we are and the way the world works
and it was a big experience I have not
acted since I spent a lot of time with
Stephen and talking to Stephen and
family videos and
audio and photographs and it was sort of
uh probably unprecedented access into
that person's life I mean it's it's such
a trip
um but I loved this character Bert
deeply
um beautiful
person of integrity and thought and I
think deep love but maybe not somebody
who always knows how to express it
[Music]
Ruby Sparks
it's almost like I'm writing to spend
time with her who the girl the one I'm
writing it's
I go to sleep at night just waiting to
get to my typewriter again so I can be
with her it's like
it's like I'm falling in love with her
that's wonderful no it's not I can't
fall in love with the girl I write why
not so my partner Zoe started writing
this script and I don't know what this
says about me but I think I sort of
assumed it was like she was writing it
for me or something just to build a
movie from the ground up and be a part
of that process the amount of love and
care you put into it and what it then
means to you and I think one of the
profound experiences on that aside from
making something with Zoe was also just
being on the other side of the casting
table and seeing how many like wonderful
and beautiful actors there are and
seeing that oh like
every it's not about who's like good or
who's bad or who's the best it's like
whose Essence is right for this part and
I remember there was a recovery period
from Ruby Sparks when Zoe and I had to
figure out like what else we talked
about at the dinner table and I would
say that that's the the hardest part of
working together
oh I have to pee
I don't remember over talking with Zoe
about the character
because you know you're meant to
interpret it and if the writing's good I
think what she's saying through it is
clear
prisoners
[Music]
hey give me a flashlight sir show me
where those girls they're in the woods
people people's lost love prisoners this
is one of those that you don't really
want to do but you do if you know what I
mean I'd seen Denise film on Sunday and
he told me Roger Dickens was shooting it
who I just had a massive crush on do I
want to play that part no like really
like no but like yeah actually I can see
it and I sort of like see a way in and
ah and then soon enough here
you're doing it one of the important
moments in the development of that was
just
I remember thinking okay if you've had
that much trauma as a kid you know what
happens when we're scared and what
happens to our body and just like okay
what would happen if you just kept
living with that and so I think a way
into that character for me was just
through the physicality
um of how I helped my body and my jaw
even because I needed to find a way out
for my own mental health I needed to
find a way to step in and out of that I
knew I did not want to engage with that
material Brian Wilson and love and mercy
that's something where you're going to
stay in the soup the the for the time
you're doing it
um it's easier to actually like once
you're in those Waters like stay in them
but with something like that I was like
how do I Paul learn how to and and it
was a lot of it was through physicality
and sort of saying okay if my body's
like this I'm entering into that
character and and then you know can I
exit out of it easier
yeah luckily Hugh Jackman was like the
nicest dude in the world it's true what
everybody says he's just uh super
sweetie and so if you're gonna get
beaten by somebody it's it's uh nice to
have Hugh on the other end of it
yeah I think I didn't know that was
coming yeah but I felt some good good
enough hands each time you're trying to
trick yourself into like learning how to
do it all again to keep it you know
uh I remember on 12 Years a Slave
actually
was so good at pulling a punch that we
had to do and I was like how does he do
that because you know and I remember
being like I just felt stupid I was like
you know just just hit me with the whip
because I don't have to act this